[MUSIC PLAYING]
CORBETT: Welcome, on behalf
of the Program in Writing
and Humanistic Studies and
the Center for Bilingual
and Bicultural Studies.
When I see a photograph of
Jhumpa Lahiri in the New York
Times or The New Yorker, I don't
think hot young fiction writer,
but instead, friend
of my daughter Marni.
And I remember the year or
so that Jhumpa and Marni
worked at WordsWorth
bookstore in Cambridge.
They tore up the place.
I liked to go in and browse
just to hear them laugh.
They were at that stage of
discovering their friendship
when everything is hilarious.
I can still hear them
bawl out-- oh, my god!
[LAUGHTER]
At some juicy bit of gossip
or off-the-charts exploit.
Some time after
this, Jhumpa asked
me to read one of
her early stories.
I did so, felt lukewarm
about it, and told her so.
She never showed me
another one of her stories.
[LAUGHTER]
I respect her for this.
Writers ought to be
ruthless about their art.
And they need to know where to
go to get what they require.
Jhumpa began to find
what she needed while
in the BU writing program,
and more and more in herself.
As one thing led to another,
and with the publication
of Interpreter of Maladies,
she became a star.
She began as a paperback writer
and graduated to hardcover.
Who knows how this happened?
Bad things happen
to good writers.
And when good things
happen to deserving ones,
it's not easy to figure out why.
A possible explanation
occurred to me
when I began to
see Jhumpa grouped
with Indian and Asian writers.
Her work tells, at least on one
level, the old American tale
of here and there, the old
country and the new world,
the tale that has been ours
since the Great Immigration
at the end of the 19th and
beginning of the 20th century,
the tale told by Saul
Bellow and James Baldwin,
by Jamaica Kincaid, and writers
will leap into all your minds.
It is the American story of
who we are, how we know it,
and the anxieties and
exhilarations involved.
Not that this answers the
question, which in the end
does not matter.
Jhumpa's work has struck a
nerve, or you wouldn't be here.
Jhumpa, the audience is yours.
[APPLAUSE]
LAHIRI: Wow.
[LAUGHTER]
Good evening.
I am very pleased to be here.
Thank you all for coming.
I want to thank everyone at
MIT for having me here tonight.
MIT was, as some
of you may know,
the first place my father
worked in this country, when
he moved here with me
and my mother in 1969.
And I'm honored that it's the
first university in Boston
that's asked me to read.
I especially want to thank Bill
and his wife, Beverly Corbett--
I want to thank Bill for his
very kind words just now--
but for their efforts
and their generosity
and their incredible
hospitality,
which I've been a recipient
of for a long time now.
I first met them 11 years ago,
right around this time of year.
As Bill mentioned, I was--
I am a friend of their
daughter Marni's.
And at the time, I had
just moved to Boston.
I'd just graduated from college.
And I moved to Cambridge.
And I was living in
a room of the home
of a woman with these two,
shall we say, very strident
young children.
And I sort of lived in this
little room behind their living
room, and felt very--
very not at home.
There were all sorts of
rules I had to abide by.
I couldn't have visitors
after a certain hour.
I had to wipe down
the stove every time
I boiled water for tea--
all of these things.
Was not a very ideal situation.
And it was around that time
that Marni invited me to dinner
at her parents' house.
I remember it was
a Sunday night.
And I had directions
to go to the South End.
I'd never been to
the South End before.
I got on the Orange Line
and went the wrong way;
found myself heading
rapidly toward Oak Grove.
Turned back around and made
it, eventually, to their house.
And was immediately
just so struck.
Those first weeks of my
life in Boston were very--
they weren't too pleasant.
And all of a sudden, I
felt wonderfully at home.
And I discovered a beautiful
home and beautiful people
and good food, and rules
that were decidedly relaxed--
[LAUGHTER]
Compared to my own lodgings.
And that was the first of many
nights I spent in their home,
and many delicious dinners
I ate at their table--
another of which I'm about
to have in a few hours.
I'm looking forward to it.
[LAUGHTER]
And I also want to say that
it was also around this time
that I went to my first
reading in Boston.
And that was one
of Bill's readings.
He was reading from his book
On Blue Note up at Harvard.
And I remember going
with Marni and Beverly,
and feeling very
excited about this.
Until I met Bill, I hadn't
known a writer before.
Writers were, to me, names
on the covers of books.
But they weren't people.
And I was amazed,
over the months
that I grew to know their
family, that here was
this man who had a
family and a house,
and wrote all these
books, and had a life,
and even managed to throw all
these amazing dinner parties.
And so I want to thank him
for that wonderful example.
And I think that if I could
write half as many books
and throw half as many
successful dinner parties,
I will be very grateful.
Anyway, so after Bill
asked me to come up here,
I realized-- this had not
occurred to me until then--
but I realized that I mention
MIT in not one but two
of the stories in my book.
Go figure.
I didn't study here.
But I thought I'd read from one
of them in honor of my being
here tonight.
This one is called
"This Blessed House."
I'll read the whole thing.
They discovered the first one
in a cupboard above the stove,
beside an unopened
bottle of malt vinegar.
"Guess what I found?"
Twinkle said.
She walked into the living
room, lined from end
to end with taped-up
packing boxes,
waiving the vinegar in one
hand and a white porcelain
effigy of Christ, roughly
the same size as the vinegar
bottle, in the other.
Sanjeev looked up.
He was kneeling on
the floor, marking
with ripped bits of
a Post-it patches
on the baseboard that needed
to be retouched with paint.
"Throw it away."
"Which?"
"Both."
"But I can cook something
with the vinegar.
It's brand new."
"You've never cooked
anything with vinegar."
"I'll look something up
in one of those books
we got for our wedding."
Sanjeev turned back
to the baseboard
to replace a Post-it scrap
that had fallen to the floor.
"Check the exploration.
And at the very least, get
rid of that idiotic statue."
"But it could be
worth something.
Who knows?"
She turned it upside down, then
stroked with her index finger
the minuscule frozen
folds of its robes.
"It's pretty."
"We're not Christians,"
Sanjeev said.
Lately he had begun
to notice the need
to state the obvious to Twinkle.
[LAUGHTER]
The day before he
had to tell her
that if she dragged
her end of the bureau
instead of lifting it, the
parquet floor would scratch.
She shrugged.
"No, we're not Christian.
We're good little Hindus."
She planted a kiss on
top of Christ's head,
then placed the statue on
top of the fireplace mantle,
which needed, Sanjeev
observed, to be dusted.
By the end of the
week the mantle
had still not been dusted.
It had, however, come
to serve as a display
shelf for a sizable collection
of Christian paraphernalia.
[LAUGHTER]
There was a 3D postcard
of Saint Francis done
in four colors, which
Twinkle had found
taped to the back of
the medicine cabinet,
and a wooden cross key chain
which Sanjeev had stepped on
with bare feet as he was
installing extra shelving
in Twinkle's study.
There was a framed
paint-by-number
of the three wise men against a
black velvet background tucked
in the linen closet.
There was also a
tile trivet depicting
a blond, unbearded Jesus
delivering a sermon
on a mountain top, left
in one of the drawers
of the built-in china
cabinet in the dining room.
"Do you think the previous
owners were born-agains?"
asked Twinkle, making
room the next day
for a small plastic
snow-filled dome containing
a miniature nativity scene found
behind the pipes of the kitchen
sink.
Sanjeev was organizing
his engineering texts
from MIT in alphabetical
order on a bookshelf--
[LAUGHTER]
though it had been
several years since he had
needed to consult any of them.
After graduating, he moved
from Boston to Connecticut
to work for a firm
near Hartford.
And he had recently
learned that he
was being considered for the
position of vice president.
At 33 he had a secretary of
his own and a dozen people
working under his supervision,
who gladly supplied him
with any information he needed.
Still, the presence of his
college books in the room
reminded him of a
time in his life
he recalled with
fondness, when he
would walk each evening
across the Mass Avenue Bridge
in order to order mughlai
chicken with spinach
from his favorite Indian
restaurant on the other side
of the Charles, and
return to his dorm
to write out clean copies
of his problem sets.
"Or perhaps it's an attempt to
convert people," Twinkle mused.
"Clearly the scheme has
succeeded in your case."
[LAUGHTER]
She disregarded him, shaking
the little plastic dome
so that snow swirled
over the manger.
He studied the
items on the mantle.
It puzzled him that each was,
in its own way, so silly.
Clearly they lacked a
sense of sacredness.
He was further puzzled that
Twinkle, who normally displayed
good taste, was so charmed.
These objects meant
something to Twinkle,
but they meant nothing to him.
They irritated him.
"We should call the
realtor, tell him there's
all this nonsense left behind.
Tell him to take it away."
"Oh Sanj," Twinkle groaned.
"Please, I would feel
terrible throwing them away.
Obviously they were
important to the people
who used to live here.
It would feel--
I don't know, sacrilegious
or something."
"If they're so
precious, then why
are they hidden
all over the house?
Why didn't they take
them with them?"
"There must be
others," Twinkle said.
Her eyes roamed the bare
off-white walls of the room,
as if there were other things
concealed behind the plaster.
"What else do you
think we'll find?"
But as they unpacked their
boxes and hung up their winter
clothes and the silk paintings
of elephant processions
bought on their honeymoon
in Jaipur, Twinkle,
much to her dismay,
could not find a thing.
Nearly a week had passed
before they discovered,
one Saturday afternoon,
a larger-than-life-sized
watercolor poster of Christ,
weeping translucent tears
the size of peanut shells and
sporting a crown of thorns,
rolled up behind a radiator
in the guest bedroom.
Sanjeev had mistaken
it for a window shade.
"Oh, we must!
We simply must put it up.
It's too spectacular."
[LAUGHTER]
Twinkle lit a
cigarette and began
to smoke it with relish,
waving it around Sanjeev's head
as if it were a conductor's
baton as Mahler's Fifth
Symphony roared from
the stereo downstairs.
"Now look.
I will tolerate for now your
little biblical menagerie
in the living room.
But I refuse to
have this," he said,
flicking at one of the
painted peanut tears,
"displayed in our home."
Twinkle stared at him,
placidly exhaling,
the smoke emerging in two thin
blue streams from her nostrils.
She rolled up the poster
slowly, securing it
with one of the elastic
bands she always wore around
her wrist for tying back
her thick, unruly hair,
streaked here and
there with henna.
"I'm going to put it in my
study," she informed him.
"That way, you don't
have to look at it."
"What about the house-warming?
They'll want to
see all the rooms.
I've invited people
from the office."
She rolled her eyes.
Sanjeev noted that the symphony,
now in its third movement,
had reached a
crescendo, for it pulsed
with the telltale
clashing of symbols.
"I'll put it behind
the door," she offered.
"That way, when they
peek in, they won't see.
Happy?"
He stood watching her as she
left the room with her poster
and her cigarette.
A few ashes had
fallen to the floor
where she'd been standing.
He bent down, pinched
them between his fingers,
and deposited them
in his cupped palm.
The tender fourth movement,
the adagiato, began.
During breakfast Sanjeev
had read in the liner notes
that Mahler had
proposed to his wife
by sending her the manuscript
of this portion of the score.
Although there were elements
of tragedy and struggle
in the Fifth
Symphony, he had read,
it was principally music
of love and happiness.
He heard the toilet flush.
"By the way," Twinkle hollered,
"if you want to impress people,
I wouldn't play this music.
It's putting me to sleep."
[LAUGHTER]
Sanjeev went to the bathroom
to throw away the ashes.
The cigarette butt still
bobbed in the toilet bowl,
but the tank was refilling.
So he had to wait a moment
before he could flush it again.
In the mirror of
the medicine cabinet
he inspected his
long eyelashes--
like a girl's, Twinkle
liked to tease.
Though he was of average
build, his cheeks
had a plumpness to them.
This, along with the
eyelashes, detracted,
he feared, from what he hoped
was a distinguished profile.
He was of average height
as well, and wished ever
since he had stopped
growing that he were just
one inch taller.
For this reason,
it irritated him
when Twinkle insisted
on wearing high heels,
as she had done the other
night when they ate dinner
in Manhattan.
This was the first weekend after
they'd moved into the house.
By then the mantle had already
filled up considerably,
and they had bickered about
it in the car on the way down.
But then Twinkle had drunk
four glasses of whiskey
in a nameless bar in Alphabet
City and forgot all about it.
She dragged him to a tiny
bookshop on St. Mark's Place,
where she browsed
for nearly an hour.
And when they left
she insisted they
dance a tango on the sidewalk,
in front of strangers.
Afterwards, she
tottered on his arm,
rising faintly over
his line of vision
in a pair of suede, three-inch
leopard-print pumps.
In this manner they walked
the endless blocks back
to a parking garage
on Washington Square,
for Sanjeev had heard
far too many stories
about the terrible things that
happened to cars in Manhattan.
"But I do nothing all day
except sit at my desk,"
she fretted when they
were driving home,
after he mentioned that her
shoes looked uncomfortable
and suggested that perhaps
she should not wear them.
"I can't exactly wear
heels when I'm typing."
Though he abandoned the
argument, he knew for a fact
that she didn't spend
all day at her desk.
Just that afternoon when
he got back from a run,
he found her inexplicably
in bed reading.
When he asked her why she was
in bed in the middle of the day,
she told him she was bored.
He had wanted to
say to her then,
"you could unpack some boxes.
You could sweep the attic.
You could retouch the paint
on the bathroom window sill.
And after you do
it you can warn me,
so I don't put my watch on it.
[LAUGHTER]
They didn't bother her, these
scattered, unsettled matters.
She seemed content
with whatever clothes
she found at the front of the
closet, with whatever magazine
was lying around, with whatever
song was on the radio--
content yet curious.
And now all of her
curiosity centered
around discovering
the next treasure.
A few days later when Sanjeev
returned from the office,
he found Twinkle
on the telephone,
smoking and talking to one of
her girlfriends in California,
even though it was
before five o'clock
and the long-distance
rates were at their peak.
[LAUGHTER]
"Highly-devout people,"
she was saying,
pausing every now
and then to exhale.
Each day is like
a treasure hunt.
I'm serious.
This, you won't believe.
The switch plates in the
bedroom were decorated
with scenes from the Bible--
you know, Noah's
ark and all that.
Three bedrooms, but
one is my study.
Sanjeev went to the
hardware store right away
and replaced them.
Can you imagine?
He replaced every single one."
Now it was the
friend's turn to talk.
Twinkle nodded, slouched on the
floor in front of the fridge,
wearing black stirrup pants
and a yellow chenille sweater,
groping for her lighter.
Sanjeev could smell something
aromatic on the stove,
and he picked his way carefully
across the extra-long phone
cord tangled on the
Mexican terracotta tiles.
He opened the lid of
a pot with some sort
of reddish-brown sauce
dripping over the sides,
boiling furiously.
"It's a stew I
made with the fish.
I put the vinegar in
it," she said to him--
[LAUGHTER]
Interrupting her friend,
crossing her fingers.
"Sorry, you were saying?"
She was like that--
excited and delighted
by little things,
crossing her fingers before any
remotely unpredictable event,
like tasting a new
flavor of ice cream
or dropping a
letter in a mailbox.
It was a quality he
did not understand.
It made him feel stupid,
as if the world contained
hidden wonders he could
not anticipate or see.
He looked at her face
which, it occurred to him,
had not grown out
of its girlhood,
the eyes untroubled, the
pleasing features unfirm,
as if they still had to
settle into some sort
of permanent expression.
Nicknamed after a nursery
rhyme, she had yet
to shed a childhood endearment.
Now, in the second
month of their marriage,
certain things nettled him--
the way she sometimes
spat a little
when she spoke, or
left her undergarments,
after removing them at night,
at the foot of their bed,
rather than depositing
them in the laundry hamper.
They had met only
four months before.
Her parents, who
lived in California,
and his, who still lived in
Calcutta, were old friends.
And across continents,
they had arranged
the occasion at which Twinkle
and Sanjeev were introduced--
a 16th birthday party for a
daughter in their circle--
when Sanjeev was in
Palo Alto on business.
At the restaurant they
were seated side by side
at a round table, with a
revolving platter of spare ribs
and egg rolls and chicken
wings which, they concurred,
all tasted the same.
They had concurred, too, on
their adolescent but still
persistent fondness
for Wodehouse novels
and their dislike for the sitar.
And later, Twinkle
confessed that she
was charmed by the way
Sanjeev had dutifully
refilled her teacup
during their conversation.
And so the phone calls
began, and grew longer.
And then the visits--
first he to Stanford,
then she to Connecticut,
after which Sanjeev
would save in an ash
tray left on the balcony
the crushed cigarettes
she had smoked
during the weekend.
Saved them, that is,
until the next time
she came to visit him.
And then he vacuumed the
apartment, washed the sheets,
even dusted the plant
leaves in her honor.
She was 27 and
recently abandoned,
he gathered, by an American
who had tried and failed
to be an actor.
Sanjeev was lonely, with an
excessively generous income
for a single man, and
had never been in love.
At the urging of
their matchmakers
they married in India, amid
hundreds of well-wishers
whom he barely remembered
from his childhood,
in incessant August rains under
a red and orange tent strung
with Christmas tree lights
on [? Mandavil ?] Road.
"Did you sweep the attic?"
he asked Twinkle later,
as she was folding paper
napkins and wedging them
by their plates.
The attic was the only part
of the house they had not yet
given an initial cleaning.
"Not yet.
I promise, I will.
I hope this tastes
good," she said,
planting the steaming pot
on top of the Jesus trivet.
There was a loaf of Italian
bread in a little basket,
and iceberg lettuce
and grated carrots
topped with bottled dressing
and croutons, and glasses
of red wine.
She was not terribly
ambitious in the kitchen.
She bought pre-roasted
chickens from the supermarket
and served them with potato
salad, prepared who knew when,
sold in little
plastic containers.
Indian food, she
complained, was a bother.
She detested chopping
garlic and peeling ginger,
and could not operate a blender.
And so it was Sanjeev
who, on weekends,
seasoned mustard
oil with cinnamon
sticks and cloves in order
to produce a proper curry.
He had to admit,
though, that whatever
it was that she had cooked
today, it was unusually tasty--
attractive, even, with
bright white cubes of fish
and flecks of parsley
and fresh tomatoes
gleaming in the
dark-brown red broth.
"How did you make it?"
"I made it up."
"What did you do?"
"I just put some
things into the pot
and added the malt
vinegar at the end."
[LAUGHTER]
"How much vinegar?"
She shrugged, ripping
off some bread
and plunging it into her bowl.
"What do you mean,
you don't know?
You should write it down.
What if you need
to make it again,
for a party or something?"
"I'll remember," she said.
She covered the bread basket
with a dish towel that had,
he suddenly noticed, the 10
commandments printed on it.
[LAUGHTER]
She flashed him a little
smile, giving his knee
a little squeeze
under the table.
"Face it-- this
house is blessed."
[LAUGHTER]
The house-warming
party was scheduled
for the last
Saturday in October,
and they had invited
about 30 people.
All were Sanjeev's
acquaintances,
people from the
office and a number
of Indian couples in the
Connecticut area, many of whom
he barely knew, but
who had regularly
invited him in his bachelor
days to supper on Saturdays.
He often wondered why they
included him in their circle.
He had little in common
with any of them.
But he always attended
their gatherings,
to eat spiced chickpeas and
shrimp cutlets, and gossip
and discuss politics, for
he seldom had other plans.
So far, no one had met Twinkle.
Back when they
were still dating,
Sanjeev didn't want to waste
their brief weekends together
with people he associated
with being alone.
Other than Sanjeev and an
ex-boyfriend, who she believed
worked in a pottery
studio in Brookfield,
she knew no one in the
state of Connecticut.
She was completing
her master's thesis
at Stanford, a study
of an Irish poet
whom Sanjeev had never heard of.
Sanjeev had found
the house on his own,
before leaving for the
wedding, for a good price
in a neighborhood with
a fine school system.
He was impressed by the
elegant curved staircase
with its wrought iron
banister, and the dark wooden
wainscotting, and the solarium
overlooking rhododendron
bushes, and the
solid brass 22, which
also happened to be
the date of his birth,
nailed impressively to
the vaguely Tudor facade.
There were two working
fireplaces, a two-car garage,
and an attic suitable for
converting into extra bedrooms
if, the realtor mentioned,
the need should arise.
By then Sanjeev had
already made up his mind,
was determined that
he and Twinkle should
live there together forever.
And so he had not
bothered to notice
the switch plates covered
with biblical stickers,
or the transparent decal of
the Virgin on a half shell,
as Twinkle liked to call
it, adhered to the window
in the master bedroom.
[LAUGHTER]
When, after moving in, he
tried to scrape it off,
he scratched the glass.
The weekend before
the party they
were raking the lawn when
he heard Twinkle shriek.
He ran to her,
clutching his rake,
worried that she had discovered
a dead animal or a snake.
A brisk October breeze
stung the tops of his ears
as his sneakers crunched
over brown and yellow leaves.
When he reached her
she had collapsed
on the grass, dissolved
in nearly silent laughter.
Behind an overgrown
forsythia bush
was a plaster Virgin Mary
as tall as their waists,
with a blue painted hood
draped over her head,
in the manner of
an Indian bride.
Twinkle grabbed at
the hem of her t-shirt
and began wiping away the dirt
staining this statue's brow.
"I suppose you want to put
her by the foot of our bed,"
Sanjeev said.
[LAUGHTER]
She looked at him, astonished.
Her belly was
exposed, and he saw
that there were goosebumps
around her navel.
"What do you think?
Of course we can't put
this in our bedroom."
"We can't?"
"No, silly Sanj.
This is meant for
outside, for the lawn.
[LAUGHTER]
"Oh god, no.
Twinkle, no."
"But we must.
It would be bad luck not to."
"All the neighbors will see.
They'll think we're insane."
[LAUGHTER]
"Why?
For having a statue of the
Virgin Mary on our lawn?
Every other person
in this neighborhood
has a statue of
Mary on the lawn.
We'll fit right in."
[LAUGHTER]
"We are not Christian."
"So you keep reminding me."
She spat onto the
tip of her finger
and started to rub intently at
a particularly stubborn stain
on Mary's chin.
"Do you think this is dirt,
or some kind of fungus?"
[LAUGHTER]
He was getting nowhere
with her, with this woman
whom he had known
only for four months
and whom he had married,
this woman with whom he now
shared his life.
He thought, with a
flicker of regret,
of the snapshots his mother
used to send him from Calcutta
of prospective brides
who could sing and sew,
and season lentils without
consulting a cookbook.
[LAUGHTER]
Sanjeev had considered
these women,
and even ranked them
in order of preference,
but then he had met Twinkle.
"Twinkle, I can't have
the people I work with
see this statue on my lawn."
"They can't fire you
for being a believer.
[LAUGHTER]
It would be discrimination."
"That's not the point."
"Why does it matter to you so
much what other people think?"
"Twinkle, please."
He was tired.
He let his weight
rest against his rake
as she began dragging the statue
toward an oval bed of myrtle
beside the lamppost that
flanked the brick pathway.
"Look, Sanj, she's so lovely."
He returned to
his pile of leaves
and began to deposit them by
handfuls into a plastic garbage
bag.
Over his head, the
blue sky was cloudless.
One tree on the lawn was still
full of leaves, red and orange,
like the tent in which
he had married Twinkle.
He did not know if he loved her.
He said he did, when she first
asked him one afternoon in Palo
Alto, as they sat side by
side in a darkened, nearly
empty movie theater.
Before the film, one
of her favorites--
something in German that he
found extremely depressing--
she had pressed
the tip of her nose
to his, so that he
could feel the flutter
of her mascara-coated eyelashes.
That afternoon he had
replied, yes, he loved her.
And she was delighted, and
fed him a piece of popcorn,
letting her finger linger
an instant between his lips,
as if it were his
reward for coming up
with the right answer.
Though she did not
say it herself,
he assumed that
she loved him too.
But now he was no longer sure.
In truth, Sanjeev did not
know what love was, only
what he thought it was not.
It was not, he had
decided, returning
to an empty carpeted
condominium each night,
and using only the top
fork in his cutlery drawer,
and turning away politely
at those weekend dinner
parties when the
other man eventually
put their arms around the waists
of their wives and girlfriends,
leaning over every now and
then to kiss their shoulders
or necks.
It was not sending away for
classical musical CDs by mail,
working his way methodically
through the major composers
that the catalog recommended,
and always sending his payments
in on time.
In the months before
meeting Twinkle,
Sanjeev had begun
to realize this.
"You have enough money in the
bank to raise three families,"
his mother reminded
him when they
spoke at the start of
each month on the phone.
"You need a wife to
look after and love."
Now he had one, a pretty one
from a suitably high caste, who
would soon have a
master's degree.
What was there not to love?
That evening, Sanjeev poured
himself a gin and tonic,
drank it and most of another
during one segment of the news,
and then approached Twinkle,
who was taking a bubble bath,
for she announced that her limbs
ached from raking the lawn--
something she had
never done before.
He didn't knock.
She had applied a bright
blue mask to her face,
was smoking and sipping
some bourbon with ice,
and leafing through
a fat paperback
book whose pages had buckled
and turned gray from the water.
He glanced at the cover.
The only thing written on
it was the word "Sonnets"
in dark red letters.
He took a breath, and then
he informed her very calmly
that after finishing
his drink, he
was going to put on his shoes
and go outside and remove
the Virgin from the front lawn.
"Where are you going
to put it?" she
asked him dreamily,
her eyes closed.
One of her legs emerged,
unfolding gracefully
from the layer of suds.
She flexed and pointed her toes.
"For now I'm going to
put it in the garage.
Then tomorrow morning
on my way to work,
I'm going to take
it to the dump."
"Don't you dare."
She stood up, letting the book
fall into the water, bubbles
dripping down her thighs.
"I hate you," she informed him,
her eyes narrowing at the word
hate.
She reached for her
bathrobe, tied it
tightly about her
waist, and padded down
the winding staircase,
leaving sloppy wet footprints
along the parquet floor.
When she reached the
foyer Sanjeev said,
"are you planning on
leaving the house that way?"
He felt a throbbing
in his temples,
and his voice revealed an
unfamiliar snarl when he spoke.
"Who cares?
Who cares what way
I leave this house?"
"Where are you planning
on going at this hour?"
"You can't throw
away that statue.
I won't let you."
Her mask, now dry, had
assumed an ashen quality,
and water from her hair
dripped onto the caked contours
of her face.
"Yes I can.
I will."
"No," Twinkle said, her
voice suddenly small.
This is our house.
We own it together.
The statue was a
part of our property.
She had begun to shiver.
A small pool of bath water had
collected around her ankles.
He went to shut
a window, fearing
that she would catch cold.
Then he noticed that some
of the water dripping down
her hard blue face was tears.
"Oh god, Twinkle, please--
I didn't mean it."
He had never seen her cry
before, had never seen
such sadness in her eyes.
She didn't turn away or
try to stop the tears.
Instead, she looked
strangely at peace.
For a moment she closed her
lids, pale and unprotected
compared to the blue that
caked the rest of her face.
Sanjeev felt ill,
as if he had eaten
either too much or too little.
She went to him, placing
her damp toweled arms
about his neck, sobbing into
his chest, soaking his shirt.
The mask flaked
onto his shoulders.
In the end, they
settled on a compromise.
The statue would be
placed in a recess
at the side of the
house, so that it wasn't
obvious to passers by, but
was still clearly visible
to all who came.
The menu for the party
was fairly simple.
There would be a
case of champagne,
and samosas from an Indian
restaurant in Hartford,
and big trays of rice with
chicken and almonds and orange
peels, which Sanjeev had spent
the greater part of the morning
and afternoon preparing.
He had never entertained on
such a large scale before
and, worried that there
would not be enough to drink,
ran out at one point
to buy another case
of champagne just in case.
For this reason he burned
one of the rice trays,
and had to start it over again.
Twinkle swept the
floors, and volunteered
to pick up the samosas.
She had an appointment
for a manicure
and a pedicure in
that direction anyway.
Sanjeev had planned to
ask if she would consider
clearing the menagerie off the
mantle, if only for the party.
But she had left while
he was in the shower.
She was gone for a
good three hours,
and so it was Sanjeev who
did the rest of the cleaning.
By 5:30 the entire house
sparkled, with scented candles
that Twinkle had picked up
in Hartford illuminating
the items on the mantle,
and slender stalks
of burning incense planted
into the soil of potted plants.
Each time he passed the mantle
he winced, dreading the raised
eyebrows of his
guests as they viewed
the flickering ceramic
saints, the salt
and pepper shakers designed
to resemble Mary and Joseph.
[LAUGHTER]
Still, they would be impressed,
he hoped, by the lovely bay
windows and shining
parquet floors,
the impressive
winding staircase,
the wooden wainscotting, as
they sipped champagne and dipped
samosas into chutney.
Douglas, one of the new
consultants at the firm,
and his girlfriend Nora
were the first to arrive.
Both were tall
and blond, wearing
matching wire-rimmed glasses
and long black overcoats.
Nora wore a black hat full
of sharp thin feathers
that corresponded to the
sharp thin angles of her face.
Her left hand was
joined with Douglas's.
In her right hand was
a bottle of cognac
with a red ribbon wrapped
around its neck, which
she gave to Twinkle.
"Great lawn, Sanjeev,"
Douglas remarked.
We've got to get that rake
out ourselves, sweetie.
And this must be--" "My
wife, [? Donima." ?]
"Call me Twinkle."
"What an unusual
name," Nora remarked.
Twinkle shrugged.
"Not really.
There's an actress in
Bombay named Dimple Kapadia.
She even has a
sister named Simple.
[LAUGHTER]
Douglas and Nora raised their
eyebrows simultaneously,
nodding slowly, as if to let
the absurdity of the name
settle in.
"Pleased to meet you, Twinkle."
"Help yourself to champagne.
There's gallons."
"I hope you don't mind
my asking," Douglas said,
"but I noticed a
statue outside, and--"
[LAUGHTER]
"Are you guys Christian?
I thought you were Indian."
"There are Christians in
India," Sanjeev replied,
"but we are not."
"I love your outfit,"
Nora told Twinkle.
"And I adore your hat.
Would you like the grand tour?"
The bell rang again,
and again, and again.
Within minutes, it
seemed, the house
had filled with bodies
and conversations
and unfamiliar fragrances.
The women wore heels
and sheer stockings,
and short black dresses
made of crepe and chiffon.
They handed their
wraps and coats
to Sanjeev, who draped
them carefully on hangers
in the spacious coat closet,
though Twinkle told people
to throw their things on the
ottomans in the solarium.
Some of the Indian women
wore their finest saris,
made with gold filigree that
draped in elegant pleats
over their shoulders.
The men wore jackets and ties
and citrus-scented aftershaves.
As people filtered from
one room to the next,
presents piles onto the
long cherrywood table
that ran from one end of the
downstairs hall to the other.
It bewildered
Sanjeev that it was
for him and his
house and his wife
that they had all
gone to so much care.
The only other time in his
life that something similar had
happened was his wedding.
But somehow this was
different, for these were not
his family but people
who knew him only
casually and, in a
sense, owed him nothing.
Everyone congratulated him.
Lester, another
coworker, predicted
that Sanjeev would be
promoted to vice president
in two months, maximum.
People devoured the samosas
and dutifully admired
the freshly-painted ceilings
and walls, the hanging plants,
the bay windows, the silk
paintings from Jaipur.
But most of all they admired
Twinkle and her brocaded salwar
kameez, which was the
shade of a persimmon,
with a low scoop in the back,
and a little string of white
rose petals she had coiled
cleverly around her head,
and the pearl choker with
a sapphire at its center
that adorned her throat.
Over hectic jazz records played
under Twinkle's supervision,
they laughed at her
anecdotes and observations,
forming a widening circle around
her while Sanjeev replenished
the samosas that he kept
warming in the oven,
and getting ice for
people's drinks,
and opening more
bottles of champagne--
with some difficulty, and
explaining for the 40th time
that he wasn't Christian.
[LAUGHTER]
It was Twinkle who led them
in separate groups up and down
the winding staircase to
gaze at the back lawn,
to peer down the cellar steps.
"Your friends adore the
poster in my study,"
she mentioned to
him triumphantly,
placing her hand on the small of
his back as they, at one point,
brushed past each other.
Sanjeev went to
the kitchen, which
was empty, and ate a piece
of chicken out of the tray
on the counter with
his fingers because he
thought no one was looking.
He ate a second piece,
then washed it down
with a gulp of gin
straight from the bottle.
"Great house.
Great rice."
Junil, an anaesthesiologist,
walked in,
spooning food from his
paper plate into his mouth.
"Do you have more champagne?"
"Your wife's wow," added
Prabal, following behind.
He was an unmarried
professor of physics at Yale.
For a moment Sanjeev stared
at him blankly, then blushed.
Once at a dinner
party Prabal had
pronounced that Sophia Loren
was wow, as was Audrey Hepburn.
"Does she have a sister?"
Junil picked a raisin
out of the rice tray.
"Is her last name little star?"
[LAUGHTER]
The two men laughed and started
eating more rice from the tray,
plowing through it with
their plastic spoons.
Sanjeev went down to the
cellar for more liquor.
For a few minutes he
paused on the steps
in the damp, cool silence,
hugging the second crate
of champagne to his chest
as the party drifted
above the rafters.
Then he set the reinforcements
on the dining table.
"Yes, everything.
We found them all in the house,
in the most unusual places,"
he heard Twinkle saying
in the living room.
"In fact, we keep finding them."
"No!"
"Yes.
Every day is like
a treasure hunt.
It's too good.
God only knows what
else we'll find--
no pun intended."
[LAUGHTER]
That was what started it.
As if by some unspoken
pact, the whole party
joined forces and began combing
through each of the rooms--
[LAUGHTER]
Opening closets on
their own, peering
under chairs and cushions,
feeling behind curtains,
removing books from bookcases.
Groups scampered, giggling
and swaying, up and down
the winding staircase.
"We've never
explored the attic,"
Twinkle announced suddenly,
and so everybody followed.
"How do we get up there?"
"There's a ladder in
the hallway, somewhere
in the ceiling."
Wearily Sanjeev followed
at the back of the crowd
to point out the
location of the ladder,
but Twinkle had already
found it on her own.
"Eureka!"
she hollered.
Douglas pulled the chain
that released the steps.
His face was flushed, and he
was wearing Nora's feathered hat
on his head.
[LAUGHTER]
One by one the
guests disappeared,
men helping women as they
placed their strappy high heels
on the narrow slats
of the ladder,
the Indian women
wrapping the free ends
of their expensive saris
into their waistbands.
The men followed behind,
all quickly disappearing,
until Sanjeev alone
remained at the top
of the winding staircase.
Footsteps thundered
over his head.
He had no desire to join them.
He wondered if the
ceiling would collapse--
[LAUGHTER]
Imagined for a split second
the sight of all the tumbling
drunk, perfumed bodies
crashing tangled around him.
He heard a shriek, and
then rising, spreading
waves of laughter
in discordant tones.
Something fell.
Something else shattered.
He could hear them
babbling about a trunk.
They seemed to be
struggling to get it open,
banging feverishly
on its surface.
He thought perhaps Twinkle
would call for his assistance,
but he was not summoned.
He looked about the
hallway and to the landing
below, at the champagne
glasses and half-eaten samosas,
and napkins smeared
with lipstick
abandoned in every corner,
on every available surface.
Then he noticed that
Twinkle in her haste
had discarded her
shoes altogether,
for they lay by the
foot of the ladder,
black patent-leather
mules with heels
like golf tees, open
toes, and slightly soiled
silk labels on the instep
where her soles had rested.
He placed them in the
doorway of the master bedroom
so that no one would
trip when they descended.
He heard something
creaking open slowly.
The strident voices had
subsided to an even murmur.
It occurred to Sanjeev that he
had the house all to himself.
The music had ended and he
could hear, if he concentrated,
the hum of the refrigerator
and the rustle of the last
leaves on the trees outside and
the tapping of their branches
against the window panes.
With one flick of his hand
he could snap the ladder back
on its spring into the
ceiling, and they would
have no way of getting down--
[LAUGHTER]
Unless he were to pull
the chain and let them.
He thought of all the things
he could do undisturbed.
He could sweep Twinkle's
menagerie into a garbage bag
and get in the car and
drive it to the dump,
and tear down the
poster of weeping Jesus,
and take a hammer to the
Virgin Mary while he was at it.
[LAUGHTER]
Then he would return
to the empty house.
He could easily clear up the
cups and plates in an hour's
time, and pour himself
a gin and tonic,
and eat a plate of warmed rice,
and listen to his new box CD
while reading the liner
notes, so as to understand it
properly.
[LAUGHTER]
He nudged the ladder
slightly, but it was sturdily
planted against the floor.
Bodging it would
require some effort.
"My god, I need a cigarette,"
Twinkle exclaimed from above.
Sanjeev felt knots forming
at the back of his neck.
He felt dizzy.
He needed to lie down.
He walked toward the
bedroom, but stopped short
when he saw Twinkle's shoes
facing him in the doorway.
He thought of her
slipping them on her feet.
But instead of
feeling irritated,
as he had ever since they'd
moved into the house together,
he felt a pang of
anticipation at the thought
of her rushing unsteadily down
the winding staircase in them,
scratching the floor
a bit in her path.
The pang intensified
as he thought
of her rushing to the bathroom
to brighten her lipstick,
and eventually rushing to
get people their coats,
and finally rushing to
the cherrywood table
when the last guest had
left, to begin opening
their housewarming presents.
It was the same pang he used to
feel before they were married,
when he would hang up
the phone after one
of their conversations, or
when he would drive back
from the airport, wondering
which ascending plane
in the sky was hers.
"Sanj, you won't believe this."
She emerged with her back to
him, her hands over her head,
the tops of her bare
shoulder blades perspiring,
supporting something
still hidden from view.
"You got it, Twinkle?"
someone asked.
"Yes, you can let go."
Now he saw that her hands
were wrapped around it--
a solid silver bust of Christ,
the head easily three times
the size of his own.
[LAUGHTER]
It had a patrician
bump on its nose,
magnificent curly hair that
rested atop a pronounced collar
bone, and a broad
forehead that reflected
in miniature the walls and doors
and lampshades around them.
Its expression was confident,
as if assured of its devotees,
the unyielding lips
sensuous and full.
It was also sporting
Nora's feathered hat.
[LAUGHTER]
As Twinkle descended,
Sanjeev put his hands
around her waist to balance her.
And he relieved her
of the bust when
she had reached the ground.
It weighed a good 30 pounds.
The others began lowering
themselves slowly,
exhausted from the hunt.
Some trickled downstairs
in search of a fresh drink.
She took a breath, raised her
eyebrows, crossed her fingers.
"Would you mind terribly if we
displayed it on the mantle--"
[LAUGHTER]
"Just for tonight.
I know you hate it."
He did hate it.
He hated its immensity, and
its flawless, polished surface,
and its undeniable value.
He hated that it was in his
house and that he owned it.
Unlike the other
things they had found,
this contained dignity,
solemnity, beauty even.
But to his surprise,
these qualities
made him hate it all the more.
Most of all, he hated it because
he knew that Twinkle loved it.
"I'll keep it in my study
from tomorrow," Twinkle added.
"I promise."
She would never put it
in her study, he knew.
For the rest of
their days together
she would keep it on the
center of the mantle, flanked
on either side by the
rest of the menagerie.
Each time they had
guests Twinkle would
explain how she had found it.
And they would admire
her as they listened.
He gazed at the crushed
rose petals in her hair,
at the pearl and sapphire
choker at her throat,
at the sparkly crimson
polish on her toes.
He decided that these
were among the things that
made Prabal think she was wow.
His head ached from
gin and his arms ached
from the weight of the statue.
He said, "I put your
shoes in the bedroom."
"Thanks, but my feet
are killing me."
Twinkle gave his
elbow a little squeeze
and headed for the living room.
Sanjeev pressed the
massive silver face
to his ribs, careful not to
let the feathered hat slip,
and followed her.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]